[Applauso]
[Musica]
quest'oggi vorrei parlarvi di una delle
passioni della mia vita
Chi prima ad oggi aveva sentito parlare
di neuroetica forse pochi Forse nessuno
in questa sala
il nostro corpo è ciò che siamo non
possiamo Certamente cambiarlo come muta
la pelle un serpente Ma possiamo
modificarlo alterarlo in funzione del
nostro benessere tanto fisico psichico E
persino spirituale
in che modo come Se domandassi a
ciascuno di voi qui presenti in sala
Qual è l'organo Qual è la parte del suo
corpo che considera essere la più
importante quella da curare di più da
preservare Certamente le risposte
sarebbero molte diverse varie e questo è
normale
chi considera per esempio addominali
bicipiti chi le gambe chi il volto gli
occhi il naso la bocca i capelli come
quella parte del corpo da curare di più
e oggi effettivamente Pensateci ci sono
tanti specialisti che ci aiutano
personal trainer
allenatori stilisti parrucchieri
esperti di moda e quant'altro ma se vi
dicessi che la parte più importante
l'organo Che presiede tutte le altre le
organizza si trova proprio qui dentro la
nostra teca cranica mi Credereste
il cervello umano
l'organo più misterioso del nostro corpo
che con le sue 87.000 miliardi di
connessioni oggi è forse quella
struttura non soltanto più complessa
della nostra corporità e degli altri
organi sistemi apparati ma a detta degli
esperti dei neuro scienziati di oggi è
la struttura più misteriosa dell'intero
Universo questo ammasso gelatinoso di un
chilo e mezzo contenuto qui dentro
fa essere ciascuno di voi qui presenti
chi è
non c'è ombra di dubbio che il
ventunesimo secolo sia il secolo d'oro
delle neuroscienze cioè di quelle
discipline che studiano tanto lo
sviluppo come l'organizzazione la
struttura e le funzioni del sistema
nervoso in particolare del cervello
umano
effettivamente grazie al cervello e lì
tutte le informazioni dei nostri Cinque
Sensi vengono integrate le nostre
percezioni lì vengono armonizzate è nel
cervello effettivamente che
risiedono e Si coordinano pensate tutte
le dimensioni e le funzioni dell'umano
dal Movimento alla percezione alla
sensibilità ma anche le nostre memorie
le nostre idee le nostre immaginazioni i
nostri ricordi i nostri affetti le
nostre emozioni possiamo dire che il
cervello umano è veramente il tesoro più
grande che possediamo
Non a caso tanto tempo fa
grandi esperti nell'antichità avevano
parlato del cervello umano descrivendolo
in questo modo
all'interno del cervello Infatti si
formano la serenità la gioia la
malinconia il dolore e l'odio grazie ad
esso ragioniamo riflettiamo creiamo Ma
esso è anche causa di pazzia delirie
smarrimenti Questo era Ippocrate di Kos
che in una volumetto dedicato al morbo
sacro cioè all'epilessia quella che
conosciamo oggi come una patologia nota
da Giulio Cesare ad oggi
ci descrive la grandezza ma anche la
fragilità di quest'organo effettivamente
se per esempio la poetessa americana
Emily Dickinson cantava le lodi di
quest'organo e in una bellissima poesia
diceva il cervello è più esteso del
cielo più profondo del mare dello stesso
peso di Dio
D'altra parte il realismo della medicina
da sempre ha pensato e ha notato
l'estrema fragilità del cervello umano
pensate il cervello è come un cristallo
prezioso così fragile che basta poco per
scalfirlo basta così poco incluso per
romperlo
gli antichi egizi
avevano compreso come alterando e
modificando il nostro cervello potevamo
modificare tanto il movimento ma
potevamo anche incorrere in gravi
disturbi deliri cambi di personalità
imnotech medico architetto e astronomo
Egizio 5000 anni fa pensate aveva
sviluppato tutta una tecnologia per
poter trapanare la teca cranica e alcuni
dei suoi pazienti sopravvivevano anche
tempo dopo queste vere e proprie
neurochirurgia
di Crotone
Crotone è una città oggi del Sud Italia
dell'antica Magna Grecia il cognome di
Crotone
500 anni prima di Cristo aveva capito
che lo sviluppo embrionario dei polli
osservando questo sviluppo embrionario
aveva capito che il tessuti che
avrebbero originato il cervello il
sistema nervoso precedevano quelli che
avrebbero originato il nostro cuore
il cuore di questi polli ma in analogia
lo stesso anche vale lo stesso anche per
l'essere umano nel secondo secolo nel
primo secolo secondo secolo dopo Cristo
Scribonio Largo un medico Romano aveva
capito che utilizzando degli animaletti
che si chiamano torpedini una piccola
Scarica elettrica bassa frequenza era
capace di alterare quello che era
contenuto qui dentro e dare un beneficio
terapeutico ai suoi pazienti che
soffrivano di emicrania
lui fisicamente prendeva questi
animaletti e li poggiava sul capo dei
suoi pazienti una lunga storia una
lunghissima storia di quella che è la
narrativa delle neuroscienze ci fa
comprendere come Effettivamente
Sì è grande la grandezza di questo
organo ma anche è così fragile
oggi le neuroscienze cioè quelle
discipline che studiano Come si sviluppa
Come si struttura e come funziona il
nostro sistema nervoso e il nostro
cervello oggi citan ci danno tanti dati
che ci fanno capire sempre di più come
Effettivamente il cervello umano sia
l'organo e la struttura di cui dovremmo
prendere coscienza e dovremmo prenderci
sul serio cura di esso
Allora possiamo domandarci Chi è il vero
personal trainer Chi è il velo
allenatore del nostro cervello oggi si
chiama neuroetica non è una malattia ma
è quella riflessione sistematica in
formata sulle neuroscienze e sulle
interpretazioni delle stesse
neuroscienze che implicano tutte le
discipline afferenti anche alla
psicologia in tutte le sue scuole la
psichiatria ma oggi anche l'evoluzione
delle Scienze digitali avete ascoltato
anche prima l'intelligenza artificiale
Qual è lo scopo della neuroetica
Ovviamente il primo scopo fondamentale
della neuroetica è quello della
autocomprensione di noi stessi alla luce
dei dati delle neuroscienze attraverso
ciò che ci dice La scienza la scienza
neurali Oggi possiamo capire di più ciò
che dovremmo fare o ciò che dovremmo
evitare
per il benessere del nostro cervello e
come questo benessere ha un effetto
tanto sul nostro corpo come sulla nostra
psiche come sulla nostra spiritualità
pensate che effettivamente dico
spiritualità perché perché oggi ci sono
studi scientifici che prendono in
considerazione questa dimensione
dell'essere umano si parla anche persino
di neurologia e di neuronistica
ora
il cervello è l'organo più importante
della nostra corporità e ciò che ci fa
essere chi siamo
e la struttura anche che ci permette di
essere le persone che vorremmo essere
Ecco allora che quest'organo sì è
contenuto qui dentro tra le nostre due
orecchie ma realmente attraverso i
nostri stili di vita attraverso le
nostre scelte il cervello è nelle tue
mani dipende da te Grazie
[Applauso]